cadenas de solidaridad entre la
población Siria el devastador terremoto
se cobró miles de vidas y dejó a
innumerables sin hogares como aquí en la
ciudad de la taquial oeste de país esta
mujer cuenta que acogió en su casa
vecinos cuyas casas se derrumbaron
Compartiendo con ellos lo poco que tiene
antes éramos cuatro familias Ahora somos
unas 12 familias
nos destapamos para mantenerlos
calientes les ofrecemos todo lo que
podemos nuestra casa no se derrumbó solo
sufrió daños Gracias a Dios
Mientras tanto los trabajadores
humanitarios de la media luna roja
emiratívan de puerta en puerta
distribuyendo paquetes de alimentos que
contienen productos como arroz lentejas
aceite y otros alimentos esenciales
hay gobernaciones que están casi
totalmente destruidas por lo que los
emiratos árabes Unidos tomaron medidas
para proporcionar apoyo a sus hermanos
en Siria a través refugio y apoyo
psicológico nutricional y médico
en Siria y en Turquía los equipos de
rescate siguen esforzándose por
ayudarlos supervivientes
pero cada hora que pasa disminuye la
posibilidad de que sobrevivan al frío
que hace bajo los escombrosos